first conversations you have are always
about what makes something feel like
Star Wars
this is the most massive reduction I've
ever worked on
they've outdone themselves in turn two
the cysts
it makes me feel like I'm on another
planet every other day new incredible
location Croatia shed was the perfect
place to shoot canto bite wearing this
alleyway in Dubrovnik smashing speeders
that's just one of those oh my gosh what
are we doing this is amazing lemons
the other big new world is crates we
shot in Bolivia on the salt flats it's
got his red mineral covered with salt
flakes that gives it a sort of a white
blank canvas
what would a battle on a planet like
that look like
[Music]
we also shot on skellig michael off the
coast of ireland
it's very way to beat Brooklyn Skilling
shooting 8 there we go I think it's
really nice to put Luke Skywalker in
front of a camera
and turn
all right good comeback you've never
seen anything like this
there's just this magical feeling that
you get and you're transported to
another world
we are working in pretty high places
dangerous places I think it's worth it
because everything is gorgeous
hey everybody happy starburst weeks so
they're releasing some more
behind-the-scenes featurettes and there
were a couple important places in the
Star Wars universe that I wanted to talk
about before I started doing all my
review and spoilery videos so no worries
this video isn't gonna have any spoilers
for the last Jedi it's just gonna cover
stuff that Lucasfilm has announced
publicly but if you are finding me for
the first time obviously there's gonna
be a crazy amount of Star Wars dropping
this week so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even giving away IMAX gift
certificates I'll explain at the end of
the video we've already talked about the
three big new characters Rian Johnson
said that even though there are more
creatures than were in the force awakens
and rogue want combined in the last Jedi
there are really only three big new
characters that the story follows the
rest of those hundreds and hundreds of
creatures are just people that you'll
see in the background so in that same
vein even though there are a lot of new
places teased in the last Jedi they're
really only two big new locations and
that's Kanto by the casino planets you
see in this that looks very familiar
we'll talk about that in a second but
then also the salt planet crate which is
being used as a resistance base the
other sort of side reason for making
this video was to start teeing up the
idea of the Unknown Regions which is
pretty much where Rian Johnson's new
trilogy is going to be set this
mysterious place were a lot of important
people and things have happened in the
Star Wars universe but not something
that we've gotten a lot of information
about but by his explanation you can see
the very clear visual reason why they
chose to have a lot of the battles on a
salt planet because it looks like the
planet bleeds when people walk or fly
across it so it becomes this wonderful
visual metaphor for what's happening
during the battle everyone is killing
each other they're bleeding the planet
looks like it's bleeding so it just
evokes this crazy imagery it as we've
talked about before the color red is
probably the most important color in
this movie it recurs all over the place
in many different locations particularly
inside snoke's throne room and it's sort
of the de facto color of dark jedi sith
evil force users as you would think
about them
so as you
the movie just think about the idea of
color red what you know about that in
the Star Wars universe and what that
says about each of the characters
throughout their journeys for those of
you having deja vu when you're watching
this canto by its stuff obviously they
have that little Chiron that reads
Dubrovnik that's where they shot most of
the King's Landing scenes for Game of
Thrones so here's the challenge for you
when you go to see the movie when you're
watching all these canto bite scenes if
you're a big Game of Thrones fan just
trying to see if you can spot any
familiar locations from particular
episodes but obviously a lot of the
interiors are gonna be different just
because you have this futuristic society
that's built in this really old looking
place which is one of the core operating
design principles of Star Wars very worn
out dirty looking galaxy with very
advanced technology so obviously there's
a lot of other stuff going on in these
canto bite scenes but we don't want to
get into spoilers yet but just from a
design perspective just try to spot all
the Game of Thrones stuff when you're
watching this so looking at the map here
let's talk about the Unknown Regions a
little bit because we've gotten a bit of
a teaser for them after the force
awakens they revealed that that's where
the first order came from that's where
Snoke came from we know that's where
Admiral Thrawn is from and we've now
learned that Disneyland is building a
special city for Star Wars land that
you'll actually be able to go visit with
your family that's set in the Unknown
Regions so everything about the future
of Star Wars is tied to the Unknown
Regions it's implied that that's where
Rian Johnson's new trilogy is going to
take place all new characters things
that we've never seen before which when
you think about the idea of the Unknown
Regions and what might be in there makes
a lot of sense because they're trying to
get away from mining a lot of the
original trilogy and just pumping that
well dry going back to the old
characters every single time it's a real
recipe for Star Wars to get stale the
first time we heard about them was heir
to the Empire which was the introduction
of the throg character and there's
actually a lot of new Thrawn novels that
are going to be released Timothy Zahn is
actually working on a new one that's
coming up so if you're a big fan of that
character and you watched him on rebels
you get more throng through the expanded
material but after the force awakens
came out they started releasing a bunch
of material explaining what happened
after the Battle of Endor Battlefront 2
just introduced the idea of the
Emperor's
project resurrection so obviously
Palpatine to somebody that had a lot of
contingency plans he had a lot of secret
stashes and caches of weapons and
darkside artifacts so part of the idea
is that after the Battle of Endor the
actual destruction of the Empire like
the final battle where they really
crumbled and then slunk off to the
Unknown Regions was the battle of jakku
so I've already talked about that in a
couple videos but one of the Emperor's
secret caches of weapons super weapons
was on jakku the Imperial generals that
were left were going to use it to
destroy what was left of the rebellion
before they became the new republic that
went sideways one of the Imperial sub
commanders a woman took command and they
went off into the Unknown Regions using
special information that was obtained by
Palpatine through all his mapping
missions so there was actually a great
period of time where Admiral Thrawn was
tasked with mapping the Unknown Regions
because everybody knows where the
borders are but for some reason over the
last couple thousand years nobody has
actually been able to map the Unknown
Regions so it's just this vast region of
planets that Emperor Palpatine believes
holds the secret origin of the dark side
of the force so he has one of his
alkaloids you pay tashu who wants to go
there to find that once the remnants of
the empire set up base inside one of the
planets within the Unknown Regions they
become the first order they rebuild they
build the Starkiller base there and they
come back in force with Snoke in tow so
it's implied that this is where Snoke
comes from and obviously there's a
couple things that we have to wait to
talk about his character till the movie
actually comes out because I don't think
it's a spoiler to say that the last Jedi
it doesn't completely answer all the
questions you have about the characters
and the mythology it gives you a couple
clues and definitely eliminates some of
the bigger wilder theories which we'll
talk about later this week when I start
doing spoilery videos but because a lot
of these new Star Wars stories a lot of
their merchandising in the hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars that
they're pumping into Star Wars land at
Disneyland is focused on the Unknown
Regions just start focusing most of your
theories about the future of the Star
Wars universe on this area so if you
want to learn more about that obviously
go see the last Jedi this week but then
start reading the expanded material
and dig into the Thrawn stuff that
they've been publishing since the new
movie started coming out for those of
you asking about the review videos I'm
allowed to post my review Tuesday
morning so you won't have to wait that
long to find out what I thought of the
movie but leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below there's a
lot of new lore that we'll talk about
later this week when I do get to
spoilers so don't worry we'll talk about
Snoke we'll talk about Rey's parents
we'll talk about the future of Luke
Skywalker it's gonna be great so make
sure you go see the movie this weekend
and there is a new round of that ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Star Wars
related comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video battle mode bainbridge please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll announce a new
winner when I post that new Star Wars
video tomorrow but you can click here
for the last big trailer and you can
click here to learn all about titans in
the air overs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight